this trailer was supposed to come out at
9 00 a.m according to social media posts
and then the 8 o'clock am slop was like
get over here
this moral combat dude you just did a
moral comment i did the mortal kombat
the mortal kombat redband trailer has
arrived i am
so excited to check this out especially
after my night last night in my years
i've probably played at least
one time in a versus match as one of
every character in mortal kombat but i'm
not that familiar with the story so
yesterday i found myself
like let me just do like a little bit of
a dive into like these characters
backstories and lore and then before you
know it six hours passes
and i'm just like getting obsessed i end
up watching like scorpions revenge the
cap off the night
it's two in the morning and i'm like you
know what i should probably go to bed
because the treasures to come out at 9am
after learning a pretty good amount of
stuff i have a theory as to who this
coal
young guy might actually be the main
character in this
i have a couple of theories running by
you guys so first of all do a reaction
give our thoughts on the trailer and
then i'll talk about my little cole
young spiel anywho
let's do this
first
[Applause]
cool
[Music]
that's a birthmark that is a birthday
party
all over the world oh sweet
there's hanzo right there
yes oh
yes
the origin of the canai
oh man
yes lord raiden
[Music]
yes this is so fun
he didn't get a character poster
yes yes yes
you turn the blood into ice
dude
alrighty that seems like the kano
personality right there i love it
absolutely love it that looks like a
blast that looks like just like a total
blast
all right you know badass it looks fun
it looks bone crunching
you said it's so gruff i want to make i
want to hear it again
this primordial
i have to see it in the context of when
it pops up in the movie but i feel like
when it does pop up in the movie
i'm gonna put my hands up in the air
yeah this is gonna be a cheering moment
as long as they don't make him say it
like every single time it must have
slipped my mind that goro's in this
movie which is
great maybe he is the champion for
saying song again watching him here i do
kind of miss
the practical effects of the 90s movie
like this felt very i was excited to see
him because i just forgot goro was in
here
if that was revealed of all the things i
researched i totally forgot he wasn't
totally didn't know that but you know
i'm just excited to see it we're
positive moment in the final fight
where with scorpion and sub-zero and you
got cole young there
because of the fact of how even with the
structure
presented in this trailer because there
was an entertainment weekly article
where i think
it might have been the director who was
talking about how the first 10 minutes
will show you the origins of scorpion
which is part of the shurai rio i'm
assuming
and then uh the lincue clan attacks
hanzo and his family and we'll go into
all the spoilers if you didn't read the
article that the director spoiled
everybody it was all in there spoiling
stuff in interviews lately
but that's what you got to tease up here
in the trailer when you see hanzo
fighting everyone right but then you
also have the traditional mortal kombat
plot
where you're banding these warriors
together where it looks like they're
going to be under the guidance of
ryden with cole young as the main
character now
and they're going into the tournament
but then it looks like
the main side story will be about
scorpion versing sub-zero that's gonna
be the main thread it looks like that's
gonna be the finale part
and the big scene steeler will be
scorpion not just cause he's freaking
scorpion but because of the plot of this
guy and how it's gonna start off
on his story i have two theories about
cole young
the one theory that i've heard is that
maybe he's like
actually johnny really it adopts the
name by the end
i think because scorpion's family
the clan that sub-zero is from the clan
that scorpion are from they've
always been at odds with each other and
and hanzo is supposed to sort of be the
last of them until he comes back feel
like he's in some way linked to scorpion
because it seems like sub-zero is
definitely the bad guy here
and scorpion is one we're going to be
rooting for yeah and i feel like
something in cole young's blood is
connected to scorpions
one they do have him in a lot of yellow
stuff throughout these like his gloves
are yellow his shirt is yellow
it just seems that way yeah like at
least in this shot anyway yeah it seems
like it could be a very subtle sort of
set design and costuming allusion to
that
because it always struck me as a little
bit odd that we'd be
starting off with the origin of like
sub-zero and scorpion and their rivalry
and then suddenly just taking a big
shift in focus so i'm like how does this
how does the story of them all tie in
yeah that's what my mind went there like
through this guy's birthright destiny
with his birthmark that
yeah when he was born you know yeah
maybe that'll call him into the greater
family lineage
it's all theory it's more plausible to
me than johnny cage at the moment
yeah that's because of like who johnny
is but this trailer was so much fun it
really was like the the violence really
lives at the park the bone-crunching
sound effects of it all it's funny
seeing how some things are a little bit
changed
it's like i didn't expect kano and
sonya blade to be teaming up entering
into mortal kombat when i was first
hearing this line of dialogue
at the beginning of hunting a fugitive
my mind was like oh they must be hunting
must be honey k now i was like oh it
changes to sub-zero okay i don't really
know what sub-zero is doing you but
all right of course giving the origins
of how jax lost his arms
to sub-zero as well brutal that was cool
brutal i mean this is very cool
it seems like everything they threw down
on for mainly were like the sub-zero and
scorpion effects because those are the
best
oh absolutely like this made scorp this
made sub-zero alone look like the
coolest thing in the movie which
actually kind of has me excited to see
what they're not
all together showing us from scorpion's
story partly because like the ice is so
visually easy to just blow your mind
with yeah
like i really do like the way that this
does hint at two distinct plot lines of
yeah you got the tournament you got all
your cool characters
and then you've got this feud between
scorpion and sub-zero and i also liked
that this kind of crashed the two
flavors together of like the old school
like uh yeah you know it's kind of a
fighting tournament there's a certain
sort of nostalgic cheese i feel like
that comes with that but also
in an updated way that looks like it
could actually be a legitimately badass
and cool movie
yeah it's a fighting tournament to save
earth absolutely
it's gotta be kind of cheesy it's kind
of cheesy but you know i feel like
there's a sweet spot that these movies
especially for video games are like
searching to hit and this is like this
certainly looks like it could absolutely
hit it oh yeah it looks like down
dirty icky grimy yeah i love it
i love seeing like luke kane kind of go
into his old school luke kang
outfit and you can see the dragon yeah
um you don't really get much of kung lao
with the razer blade hat but he does
block something at one point in this
trailer if i'm not mistaking
uh has the laser with his eye actually
that was a bit of a surprise i did i
didn't know if that was just like some
aesthetic choice that we were just
putting in here for now and he also is
a face was obscured from the laser side
so maybe by that time that he's using it
the skin will have peeled off or
something and they're just not revealing
it yet
like rush quick editing this right now
and
is that reptile here i think that's a
reptile i didn't notice that when we
first did the reaction reptiles in here
and he looks like a reptile
it seems like what leads them to the
tournament so much is going to be
leading on
fate in so many ways oh we're hunting
sub-zero and hunting sub-zero led them
to the tournament which is kind of like
with sonia blade of
how it got her into the tournament in
the first video game
of hunting down uh kano and she wasn't
supposed to compete but then she ends up
competing but then you got some people
with like cole young with the birthmark
and all that
i feel like all that stuff with cole
young in the beginning is going to feel
like the most cheesy
that's going to be like the most
dramatic it's easy to segue from a 90s
fight movie into a modern thing
yeah as we get into the world it's going
to be like oh man you're taking yourself
too seriously this is really cheesy i'm
not feeling it and then when you finally
get to like some mortal kombat
characters in the actual world and the
tournament perhaps
i feel like that's when it's going to
get like really cool i think ryden looks
great i
i'm i hope this movie doesn't have too
much of
trying to take itself obnoxiously
serious to the point where it can feel
flat in moments where there's not action
scenes because that's my one concern
even watching this trailer is that the
action looks great that's mainly what
i'm signing up for here i just don't
want it to fall like
dull you know i still want to enjoy
being with the characters when they're
not fighting because it's still novel
having them on screen and
alive yeah it's because their aesthetics
look cool the effect like ryden looks
really cool
shang tsung looks cool they all look
cool now
i just want to get a better sense of
does will her personality shine because
even in the 90s movie as goofy as that
was they all had personality oh yeah
so that's what i would want here too is
like even if i don't need to be
i don't need to take it like serious to
be a character yeah i don't need to be
like the most
heavy heartfelt thing in the world but i
wanted to just have personality
consistently i feel like with that
statue that looks like shao kahn they're
definitely setting up for a sequel
perhaps a mortal comic cinematic
universe all right guys well what did
you think of this trailer leave your
thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button check us out for
more
last but not least
mikhail lyndon just want to say what's
up to you and send you some love from
across the world and since
my thing is big arms and linking people
to trailers
all i've been thinking about since
yesterday is your mortal kombat joke
with christopher lambert and you know
what
i think you would be great to swap into
that role i want to see you the long
flowing white hair the magic staff and
the robes and all that the electricity
i want you to join the moral combat
world i want to see you fight i want to
see you oiled up i want to see your
rippling muscles and i want to know what
your finishing move would be
how would you end my life let us know
but uh in all seriousness i hope you're
doing well across the world
i hope you're staying safe and uh much
love man be well very good
thanks macau
you